everybody knows that a child does best
being raised by a mother and a father
joined together in marriage in
perpetuity for the good of the spouses
and the sake of the generation and
education of children everybody knows it
and I know there are some people
listening right now who might say well
no it's not the best in every situation
no it's literally the best in every
single situation
is it is it better to be raised by a
single mother no it can be done there
are heroic single mothers out there
who overcome difficult odds if a husband
walks out or something
but it's not ideal it's not better than
a married mother and father single
father no not better than a married
mother and father two homosexuals no two
lesbians no how do we know that that's
not better because the implication of
that is that women have nothing to
contribute to child rearing